Aaron, the trucker is on the line from the
2 1 7.
And we haven't heard from Aaron for a while.
And I'm very interested in what's going on
with trucking right now.
Aaron, how are you?
I'm alive.
Yeah.
I'll have to say about that.
So, yeah, trucking is doing fine.
The thing about trucking is, is that unlike
a lot of things in this country, this is a
very resilient industry.
Seventy one percent of everything that you
buy is delivered on a truck.
Right.
I'm glad that you recognize me.
I only called once, but anyway.
Well, we do have the only thing that I want
to say is that.
Fair enough, fair.
The only thing I want to say is this I'm not
a leftist.
I'm an independent.
And one of the reasons for that is.
The less love, too.
I'm not saying Joe Biden is a good guy, but
the left loves to point to one thing that
Joe Biden said.
As Joe Biden being a bad guy, was Joe Biden
saying that he has no empathy for millennials
who say that is hard, he said and I quote,
If you don't like the way things are, go out
and change.
Now, the funny thing is, in many senses, that's
exactly what the left is done by electing
people like AOC, HUNT, Omar, Ayanna Pressley,
Roe Karna, the lady who just defeated Dale
of Tennessee, whose name escapes me at the
moment.
Right.
But every person on the left seems to say
that when it came to voting for Bernie Sanders,
the left didn't come out in the numbers that
they should have.
But yet I've seen so many people on the left
who refuse to vote for Joe Biden.
Mm hmm.
So it is just mind boggling to me that it
just seems to me like the left wants to have
it both ways.
They don't want to go out and actually do
what they need to do to make sure that bias
that that Sanders gets elected.
But they don't want to at the same time, they
don't want to vote for the person who is actually
likely to make this country slightly less
bad than four more years of Trump, which would
be an absolute nightmare.
I just I don't.
Well, this is a fundamental philosophical
disagreement.
Right.
There are people who believe that if it's
not going to be, Bernie, that Biden is essentially
just as bad as Trump, that Biden needs to
do something to earn their vote or otherwise.
You're basically giving a blank check to the
DNC and that they're willing to tolerate four
more years of Trump.
Trump getting Supreme Court picks.
More federal judges falling for years, further
behind on climate change, etc..
There are other people who say even if Biden
is to my right, Trump is way further to my
right.
Biden supports the Green New Deal as a framework.
Trump laughs at it and got out of Paris climate.
Biden's tax plans better than Trump's.
Biden will pick better judges than Trump.
And you're gonna do the thing that is the
least bad, as you're pointing out.
Now, I might.
I'm in that latter group.
There's some people in my audience who are
in that first group.
It's a philosophical disagreement.
Yeah, but it's it's all I'm saying is that
unless the left is really going to get it
together and really figure out what it is
that they want, then.
You can't complain about whatever happens,
whatever the ramifications are, former years
of Donald Trump.
Right.
Exactly.
If you if you participate, if you take an
action that helps Trump get reelected and
then you complain about Trump, then there
is certainly some some sort of a double standard
there for sure.
Now, Aaron, just on the trucking, is there
like is there more demand for truckers right
now because of all the people that are hoarding
stuff?
Well, let's just say the toilet paper industry
is exploding, right?
What I can tell you is there's there's been
a there's been a need for truck drivers for
years.
The Corona virus outbreak is certainly not
helping.
Well, what I can tell you is there have been
measures taken that basically waive the restrictions
that we have, the regulations that we have,
that if you're hauling food and supplies to
grocery stores, you can get them there as
soon as you can.
Wow.
And worry about getting only being able to
drive, skipping, skipping, sleep, even.
That sounds dangerous.
Yes, it sounds dangerous.
And of course, because this is America, there
are likely people who are going to show us
why that wasn't a good idea.
Yeah, the idea is that these stores desperately
need these supplies.
Right.
So.
They hope that people will use common sense.
I don't have confidence that they will, but
that yes, that's what they're doing for us.
So let me ask you this, Aaron.
Can you remind me what it's normally you can't
drive more than how many hours every how many
hours.
What's the rule?
At the rule, if you're only allowed to drive
up to 11 hours a day and you're only allowed
at 14 hours from the time you go on duty to
do that.
OK, got it.
So let me ask you this.
What do you think is a safe upper limit for
if if those restrictions were gone and you
were allowed to drive more?
How far would you push it that you believe
is still safe?
Well, for me personally, because I can only
speak for myself.
I could probably drive.
Thirteen, fourteen, maybe fifteen hours, not
straight, of course, with right of a breakthrough
between.
But yeah, probably somewhere more than twelve
hours easily.
Yeah.
And are you using any, you know, like caffeine
or anything else when you if you were to do
such a long day.
No.
OK.
Unnecessary.
All right.
Aaron, well, listen, I appreciate you calling
in.
Stay safe out there, OK?
You, too.
Thanks for putting so much emphasis on me.
All right, Aaron.
All right.
Well, we're we're following trucking very,
very closely.
All right, Aaron, thank you very much.
Don't hang up if you're holding.
We're going to take a quick break and then
we'll go right back to the phones after this.
Don't hang up if you are holding
right now.